one man is dead after a shooting at the
seagull suites not too far from unlv and
six other people were also shot two of
them in critical condition eight news
now reporter mary jane valliesa has the
story
at 11 30 p.m thursday night metro
officers responded to a shooting at the
siegel suites on flamingo and university
center drive based upon the preliminary
details that we have right now there was
a neighbor dispute
that escalated into a verbal argument
and during that verbal argument
there is an exchange of gunfire
resulting in the incident that we are
investigating right now justin bray
lives there he says he heard several
pops outside about 11 11 or so at night
two gunshots followed by about five
simultaneous ones and stepped outside
saw what door was open and
by the time i got outside saw the
officers they were giving the guy cpr
already lieutenant jason johansen says
this is especially alarming after last
weekend's shooting at manny's glow ultra
lounge i think any of these shootings
that happen in any of our neighborhoods
here are alarming to any of us and
just know that your police department
here we're doing everything we can
to solve these shootings and we will
solve these shootings mary jane valeeza
live local now